bureau du sénat a en effet décidé de
saisir la justice et de quelques a pas
des moindres puisqu'il s'agit de trois
hauts responsables de l'elysée rien
moins que le secrétaire général le
directeur de cabinet et emmanuel macron
et le chef de la sécurité pour rien de
moi non plus que des soupçons de faux
témoignages alors déjà malgré vos porte
parole du gouvernement a évidemment
réagi à cette décision du sénat dans
l'écoutent
c'est une décision politique il faut que
bureau du sénat l'assument comme telle
elle ne repose sur aucun fondement ni en
fait ni en droit au fond à l'issue de
cette procédure les masques tombent
on est dans un instrumentalisation à des
fins politiques est en revanche le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
patrick scanner à lui défendu la
décision qui avait été prise et que
soutenir son groupe
c'est l'artillerie lourde là qui est
sorti depuis ce matin par la public en
marche et quelques-uns de ses alliés est
ce que le sénat dérange dans son rôle d'
équilibre des pouvoirs
est-ce qu'il a le droit de travailler de
manière un peu autonome sans la pression
de l'exécutif est ce qu'il a le droit de
dire l'exécutif mais peut-être qu'il ya
eu des problèmes de dysfonctionnement au
sein de l'elysée sur la question de la
sécurité du président il aura une vision
plutôt benjamin griveaux ou patrick
alors écoutez moi ce que je vois c'est
que en fait là encore c'était un peu
annoncé parce que c'est les suites du
rapport qu avait rendu lé sénat et il
avait recommandé que le bureau
recommande et que l'âge est la justice
soit saisie donc on savait que ça venait
c'est venu je pense c'est clair que le
sénat s'affirme comme un contre-pouvoir
donc canton d instrumentalisation à des
fins politiques d'agir comme
contre-pouvoir oui ça une dimension
politique là je crois que par définition
quand on décide d'agir comme
contre-pouvoir
on a des effets politiques alors est ce
qu on le fait avec des motivations
politiques ou pour faire respecter la
règle de droit ça c'est une autre
question
moi je suis pas dans la tête des
sénateurs ce que je vois c'est que le
sénat puisse faire des rapports des
enquêtes de cette façon moi qui connais
un peu le
le contexte politique américain je
trouve ça intéressant de voir ses
méthodes
on a l'habitude de voir au cinéma
catalan 4 muller alors ça vient chez
nous c'est pouvoir donc aux
parlementaires et c'est un peu amusant
aussi est de voir que dans le rôle on le
sait que ce gouvernement manque de
contre-pouvoir on le sait on sait qu'il
a une assemblée nationale littéralement
aux ordres et que c'est un problème est
lent quand on retrouve le sénat gérard
larcher à sa tête
allier avec mediapart dans le rôle de
seul contre-pouvoir contre emmanuel
macron il son gouvernement c'est amusant
et étonnant maintenant sur le fond de la
faire bon je crois que dans le cas
d'alexandre benalla et vincent crasse de
toute façon c'est pas très nouveau et
d'associations dont ils sont déjà mis en
examen c'est assez clair qu'il faut
faire avec la justice
là c'est la question du faux témoignage
du chômage et du fait que luis et
d'ailleurs même les électeurs de cabinet
parce que les autres c'est des
témoignages que le sénat décrit comme
fou imprécis est-ce que c'est pas à
richard bouhet prendre un bazooka pour
parce que le transmettre à la justice
c'est pas rien
je ne sais pas d'abord on est enfin il
faut pas non plus se surprendre que le
sénat ait envie de jouer le rôle qui est
le sien avec une alliance ou senna psl
est en fait on dit cette alliance là
mais c'est pas à la regarder comme ça on
peut aussi dire que depuis le début de
ce quinquennat
emmanuel macron n'a pas donné non plus
trop de signes pour que le sénat puisse
ne pas avoir un espèce de kourou par
rapport à la politique qui est proposé
il ya un an il ya un gouvernement et un
pouvoir qui en gros ballet régulièrement
le rôle des pelles vote des
parlementaires ne respectent pas
forcément les corps intermédiaires ne
respecte pas une partie qui est au début
du quinquennat en tout cas les mères et
leurs prérogatives
bref le sénat réagi le sénateur pouvoir
et j'ai simplement qu'on vous dit c'est
une alliance entre la droite et
le parti socialiste mais c'est aussi le
lieu du contrecoup d'un contre-pouvoir
dans lequel la droite peut s'exprimer et
peut s'exercer la commission avec
philippe ballard chez comme président
c'est pas des hommes de gauche mais à un
moment donné je crois qu'il joue ce rôle
mais aussi parce que dans le contexte
politique ya pas d espace pour qui se
passe vraiment d'autre chose donc je
crois que la réaction du sénat - elle ne
me surprend pas ces salles effectivement
dû du lieu ne contre-pouvoir un lieu de
l'opposition est de bonne politique
si on suit richard brigue de répondre
par la saisine de la justice dans une
frustration politique je résume à très
gros traits c'est pas le sénat qui a
menti
les sénateurs n'ont pas non il va déjà
on est je pense qu'on est presque tous
d'accord pour dire que c'est la première
fois depuis très longtemps que senna
nous procure une émotion politique en
suis vite dit c'est en quelque sorte
réenchanter lui même ce qui était fait
avec eux et au fond il dit il a fait
quoi il a fait ce que ce que vous disiez
c'est-à-dire son travail de commission
denquête il l'a semble-t-il fait tout à
fait correctement et je trouve que
l'intervention de monsieur griveaux est
aussi vindicatif que qu'un consistante
parce que dire que le sénat fait de la
politique bah en fait oui il fait de la
politique
et c'est là enfin voilà en famille et
que à un moment le choeur la commission
denquête décide de proposer au bureau de
renvoyer un certain nombre de
collaborateurs du président de la
république ou non pas devant la justice
mais enfin de signaler à la justice
théia si je ne m'abuse au procureur un
certain nombre de fêtes au fond
si on a connaissance d'un délit ou si on
suspecte qu'il y est un délit et bien on
fait appel au procureur le plus proche
donc ça me paraît parfaitement normal ça
me paraît correspondre à un schéma
d'évolution du sénat tout à fait
intéressant du point de vue de
l'évolution de la vème république la
vème république à cette souplesse et
c'est bien qu'elle essaie bien que
l'exécutif sont un peu serrées par le
sénat ou alors sa nouvelle marque
tendresse et résurrection du sénat je me
rappelle que le fait la précédure
l'arroseur arrosé
emmanuel macron il n'a pas appelé gérard
larcher ou demandent la convocation des
hauts dignitaires de l'elysée pour le
dire mais attendez vous n'êtes pas dans
votre rôle là donc je viens il a aussi
joué un petit peu et puis il n'a pas
écrit dans sa lettre aux français qu'il
fallait supprimer le sénat
donc le réveil du sénat il aussi sur le
fait non on n'est pas morts où on existe
toujours et puis on va pas te faciliter
la tâche après est ce que c'est une
instrumentalisation politique comme le
dit grivot moi ça me fait penser
lorsqu'il ya une attaque contre un
syndicaliste on dit que c'est une
intrigue nation syndical on cherche à
briser la voix des travailleurs lorsque
que n'at-on pas dit quand françois
fillon candidat à la présidentielle
s'est pris sa mise en examen que n'a pas
dit où des clients de ba dit les autres
on est dans une instrumentalisation
classique
des opposants par rapport à un exécutif
par rapport à un pouvoir
et puis du mnr général là on est sur
légumes vient vraiment sa part on part
de la sphère benalla qui nous occupe
depuis maintenant plus de six mois avec
son lot de révélations
je dirais quasiment hebdomadaire bientôt
à cette apprendre qu il a aussi signé
des contrats avec d'autres pays que la
russie ou la chine et puis d'une manière
générale comme je sais que vous aimez
beaucoup mais mais les proverbes
animalier rappelez vous ce que disait la
grand mère de martine aubry quand c'est
flou c'est qu'il ya un loup
et là franchement je trouve que la
bergerie elle était quand même assez
chargé nos internautes sur ce sujet
grave
le sénat déclare t-il la guerre marque
le sénat déclare t-il la guerre à
l'elysée en saisissant la justice
et bah vous êtes 56 % à penser que non
leur show avec son club
finalement on va pas faire rentrer dans
peut-être dans les pubs les détails
politique de cette affaire mais est-ce
que gérard larcher mais fabrique ne
s'est pas un petit peu aussi fait
dépasser par ses propres troupes et ce
que lui même était si favorable que ça
cette décision arrive non disons que
c'est quand même une décision qui va
plus loin que ce que le sénat aurait pu
imaginer faire peut-être il ya quelques
années et donc qui est l'espèce
d'interrogation de gérard larcher je
trouve ça plutôt c'est ça aussi c'est à
gérard larcher quand même prend une
décision qui je crois est dans l'optique
de ce que plusieurs présidents de
groupes là on a entendu patrick kanner
mais je pense qu'on pourra aller sur
d'autres groupes avaient envie de faire
et les quelques interrogations qui ont
émaillé les propos notamment chez les
centristes je crois c'était pour savoir
si la qualification de ce qui était
envisagé était la bonne mais voilà je
crois enfin sur le principe même
mais je crois pas en fait que ce soit
alors là pour le coup je reprendrai les
mots de françois bayrou je ne crois pas
que ce qu'a fait le sénat est
scandaleusement révolutionnaire ronito
nous dit il semble que le sénat trouve
un moyen de justifier son existence aux
yeux des citoyens lui qui est sur la
sellette clos room nous dit d'un côté le
gouvernement a tort et à gérer cette
crise d'une façon catastrophique mais
d'un autre côté le sénat a trouvé un os
à ronger est en fait un peu trop ça
c'est la vie du club
et stéphanie le contenu du rapport sur
les trois hauts fonctionnaires est
truffé d'impression de suppositions de
conditionnels ils n'ont rien trouvé mais
veulent embêter l'exécutif c'est
lamentable
non c'est stéphanie et mimi nos dit
merci au sénat de ne pas avoir été
influencé par la crainte de voir réduire
le nombre de sénateurs comme
représailles parce qu'effectivement
parle de cela le sénat rôle important à
jouer nous dit si je suis pour renforcer
ses pouvoirs pas le supprimer
de là le sénat est tout à fait dans son
rôle de ne rien lâcher et nicole enfin
la sphère benalla est une affaire d'état
pas d'été il est normal que le sénat va
aider suite et je termine vraiment avec
patrick sans horizon proche des
élections européennes le sienna
aurait-il fait la même saisine de la
justice
on laissera la question ouverte oui vous
parliez de quand même un mot sur ce sur
l'évolution à l'américaine on anticipe
un peu mais c'est quand même là c'est le
schéma qu'on voit se dessiner la session
où effectivement on aurait un parlement
qui agit comme contre-pouvoir avec un
pouvoir exécutif et dans ce cas là si on
est dans le schéma à l'américaine il
faut aussi rappeler qu'il ya la justice
qui est le troisième terme et qu'elle
doit agir en toute indépendance
alors moi ce qui me frappe c'est que ce
modèle de séparation et d'équilibré des
pouvoirs
il est très bon c'est pas forcément
notre tradition politique mais qu'on
cherche à s'en rapprocher davantage moi
je vois ça d'un très bon oeil mais alors
il ya un certain nombre de règles du jeu
dans ces cas là qui sont très très
stricte et c'est pour ça moi il me
semble que le sénat est complètement
dans son rôle quand il ya une commission
d' enquête sur la sphère benalla et
qu'il demande à entendre tous les gens
qui sont soupçonnées de délits dans
cette affaire il est également dans son
rôle quand il se quand il quand il
choque quand il se scandalise de faux
témoignages on qu'on ne dise pas la
vérité devant une commission d enquête
du sénat même si là encore dans notre
tradition politique des truies devient
plus grande tolérance pour le mensonge
que par exemple aux états unis quand il
va se mêler de l'organisation interne de
la sécurité à l'elysée alors là c'est
peut-être un peu différent c'est le
point qui avait voulu je crois a
souligné le premier ministre dans son
intervention d envoi de la séparation
des pouvoirs je trouve ça formidable que
la justice fasse son travail dans la
sphère benalla alors que les parlements
viennent trop se mêler de la façon dont
est organisée la présidence de la
république
moi je suis pas suffisamment jury si je
dis que si on veut se réclamer de la
séparation et de l'équilibré des
pouvoirs alors il faut faire très
attention aux règles du jeu du sénat en
amérique
quant aux états unis qui n'est pas
exactement ça se voit l'arrivée rolland
sénateurs on n'est pas exactement
combary en tout cas on relance le sénat
n'a rien fait qui ne lui est pas
autorisée par la constitution française
aujourd'hui donc il n'a pas cassé des
codes outrepassé ses droits ils
appliquent les règles telles qu'elles
lui sont accordés on parle un peu de
retraite et de dépendance sans lien avec
aucun alors il ya quand même un côté un
peu poupées russes dans ce dossier parce
qu'il y avait déjà la cacophonie de
l'exécutif sur l'âge de départ à la
retraite est maintenant venue s'ajouter
la question de la dépendance
on sait on ne sait pas comment financer
les retraites des générations des
baby-boomeurs mais il faut aussi qu est
aussi s'occuper de savoir comment
financer
enfin doit assurer des conditions de vie
décentes aux personnes âgées et comment
répondre aux défis grand âge donc au
poids que c'est un peu envoyez mignot
fois que les français se demandent si le
gouvernement n'est pas en train de les
embrouiller d'essayer à la fois de leur
faire passer la pilule de l'allongement
de la durée de travail et de leur faire
peur avec le grand âge on va voir tout
cela on va voir avant d'en parler on va
écouter jean paul delevoye c'est le haut
commissaire chargé de la réforme des
retraites
il était ce matin l'invité de france
inter il estime qu' on est tous
concernés
il faut que la la créativité politique
l'intelligence citoyenne fasse prendre
conscience que nous sommes tous
concernés par ce sujet
si nous sommes tous concernés est ce que
c'est un impôt collectif que nous devons
supporter on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
souffrance un impôt fait que c'est
quelque chose qui paraît difficile et
donc
le débat doit être posée dans sa totale
dimensions sans aucune censure change
aucune réserve et agnès buzyn mise de la
santé elle estime également que les deux
sujets se rejoignent je pense que au
fond du fond il va falloir qu'on
travaille un peu plus un peu plus pour
payer la dépendance mais travaille plus
ça peut être plein de façons différentes
de travailler l'appuyer aussi une autre
marque adressé deux vrais dossiers la
retraite la dépendance je rappelle à
tout le monde est d'accord mais ces deux
défis majeurs mais est ce qu'on n'est
pas là comme me disait en présentant le
sujet un peu en train de tout mélanger
pour faire passer oui aucun des deux
sujets nés nouveau vient les retraites
avait été dit dans cette âpre au bled
qui a été identifié par les présents
république dans sa campagne électorale
et avait il a promis de faire une
réforme systémique en dix ans à l'époque
qui a pas de problème financier donc je
ferai une réforme ne toucherait pas aux
paramètres et simplement changer le
système pour le rendre plus juste plus
lisible aujourd'hui se rend compte qu'il
ya un aussi un problème financier qui a
foiré mais je mets ça de côté et ils y
apprennent de la dépendance quel une
tarte à la crème depuis plus de dix ans
je dire personne et découvre le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est dans le site et dans
la halle le programme de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 c'était dans
celui de françois hollande
il trouve que le premier n'a rien fait à
cause de la crise le deuxième ne l'a pas
fait parce qu'il a fait une pseudo loi
de 2 pour adapter la société au
vieillissement de la population
vinexpo renforcer nombre de places dans
les ehpad qui n'a pas résolu résolu le
problème
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui le problème
des devant nous il est vrai il est réel
aujourd'hui la dépendance c'est 1.1.4 de
piles c'est à dire ça à peu près 30
milliards d'euros par an dans 50 ans
dans 40 ans pardon ça va doubler en
point de pipe nous ça veut dire que ce
sont des dizaines de milliards d'euros
en plus qui va falloir trouver donc ça
ça va pas tomber du ciel
versez pas il est bien falloir trouver
une solution de financer donc ce que
c'est aujourd'hui le gouvernement s'est
habilement ou malhabilement je ne sais
pas plus tôt même plutôt malin
malhabilement il lit les deux sujets en
dix ans il va bien falloir trouver de
l'argent pour financer la dépendance est
donc l'une des solutions c'est
d'augmenter l'âge de départ à la
retraite mais sur les retraites
là on est plutôt tranquille et on va pas
l'augmenter donc on va l'augmenter
surnom n'est pas là
et sur l'autre donc ils disent aussi les
deux tout en les liant c'est assez
compliqué et franchement pour ceux qui
ont écouté jean paul delevoye ce matin
pendant 20 minutes sur france inter ils
étaient venus pour déminer le sujet pour
faire en sorte que soit beaucoup plus
clair
je mets au défi quiconque de l'avoir
compris et d'avoir une position claire à
la sortie marc henrie d'accord avec marc
sur le côté un peu alors bon et que la
dépendance soit sujet enfin une bombe
économique à retardement sas et c'est
l'évidence devait rappeler les chiffres
les deux sujets n'ont rien à voir
absolument rien à voir ni rien la
retraite c'était au départ une manière
de nom mais fier pour le pour l'année
dans le cadre de la sécurité sociale
bon le gouvernement provisoire de la
république et c'était l'idée de vieillir
dignement quand on n'était plus capable
de travailler et puis c'est devenu cette
espèce de deuxième vie payé par la
solidarité entre les actifs et les
inactifs maintenant la question est de
savoir c'est à partir de quand commence
la deuxième vie compte tenu de ces
évolutions
ça c'est un sujet et la dépendance ça
n'a rien à voir
la dépendance c'est quelqu'un qui était
pas malade qui devient malade malade au
sens où il a besoin de soins pour se
déplacer pour s'orienter pour vivre tous
les jours et donc il il a besoin d'un
homme ça n'a rien à voir du point de vue
de la situation des personnes donc
financer l'un par l'eau